hello and welcome to this video playing
whoops laughs Serbian Slav could be it's
good for this and we got a four nights
with a three uh-huh yeah yeah this is
something that I'm definitely have to
check definitely have to check yeah I
played actually d5 in a game not too
long ago but I'm a little bit uncertain
how good it really is yeah I know was
clear that he can do that nothing to do
about it
I just never I was never sure that this
is actually that big of a deal
however this looks a little bit odd for
me
they are both attacked and if I go back
here he goes probably d6 huh
it looks pretty bad I was trying to
improvise this which was not a great
idea
Wow hmm how do I actually get a playable
position from him
yeah problem these six
this is not good at all of it I mean
okay
I have going to be six now which is
interesting preventing canceling for the
moment I'm going to try that yeah maybe
I should have just played d5 I mean I
played it against in good I am with
black and had no problems whatsoever so
I mean in an in a classical tournament
game what what tag is that really okay
so I check here the 94 and this is like
rook f1 yeah you have yes what really
that works
that looks outlandish check and then
let's let's just think about this for
one moment I have Queen deform and
Queen deform Bishop no it doesn't work
so this Bishop d3 I can take it if five
and here what about rook to Queen takes
that's made on eh unfortunately made on
eight and here I don't have anything
else I cannot move the lock really it's
check there this is the thing
I think I really have to make the draw
which is a bit of a shame I don't I
don't see you win yeah rook e8 I mean
yeah I can move it but I have ten
seconds I have ten seconds and yeah so
this is completely winning but okay yeah
this is this line this line is a bit odd
a3 the the issue is um I play d5 in that
game in that classical time control game
that I mentioned in this game
my opponent replied actually lots of
proponents say they just take and play
this which essentially leads to a
foreign ID Scott reversed and White has
the extra moves a3 which is not totally
useless but almost so I think no problem
at all yeah I mean blackish should be
completely fine but after d5 an
interesting move is this one and this is
compared to the Scotch for now it's a
bit of a difference that a3 is an extra
move the point is if black takes this is
also what I did in the game White has
castles Queen e2 at 95
my opponent played Queen to e2 in that
game and after Queen to d6 we
essentially get the we got this which is
the same thing as the four Knights like
a three is an extra move that is totally
irrelevant here and black is fine I mean
black as close equal maybe slightly
better
I was actually clearly better in the
game but it's only true in this position
however there is the move Knight takes
e5 and that initiates this crazy
complications with Queen g5
six Queen to rook f-16 95 and this and
here the move a3 could be relevant
because there are Lions we're actually
filming with reversed colors where
Bishop to b5 is a key move which here
might not be yeah which is not as easily
possible as we see here the engine in
fact still gives wider cleaner to a
black a clean advantage but like to this
depth is not yet something reliable
depth 24 and his position is not
reliable maybe maybe it is some better
nevertheless with colors reversed and
the pawn back here white is almost
winning in the in the same position yeah
so if you are completely confused now my
neck let's if we're here and what does
that sorry okay you know and I know I'm
confused Bishop before right 95 and
before Quincy yeah this is this is
almost winning yeah if you know your
stuff there's a five which obviously
like with colors reverse pawn on a six
it's not a difference Queen e7 is the
thing and after Queen e7 I went to spy
to Quincy a Bishop c4 and maybe it's not
really a difference b5 and then but
should be three years one of the things
we should be 5 it's also possible but
you don't have to do it yeah I'm not
entirely certain about all this so yeah
I decided to go Bishop c5 which is
actually like running into this this is
what's idea that yes this sacrifice now
but yeah the the biggest problem here is
actually that like here no NC 685 that
you don't have Bishop
before if you had to Bishop before in
this position everything would be okay
that gives you a night only seven I mean
no but here I'm really in some sort of
trouble 95 I didn't like and TM it was
that was a real real problem they only
have six that looks definitely good yeah
white can take him maybe take him yeah
it must be better for white no no doubt
yeah I think this is giving me giving me
quite a bit of development J Queen to b6
I'm not sure it's not liked by the
engine that much and just wants to play
Queen e7 which is also certainly okay I
mean what you have to recognize is that
f4 is completely dead move is very very
harmful for white yeah you make your own
bishop on c1 look a bit stupid and it
weakens efore III and so on for example
like after castles knight c6 I can
simply develop like go d5 Quincy v check
I'm okay no I mean the engine is on
about zero
okay Queen b6 was more ambitious and
then he played this is really really
hard to move g4 Wow
yeah okay I did this g5 and Knight e4
was even better okay
this is not good yeah look at fun that
is what I was thinking and I wasn't
really sure what's going on there I am
to be honest
probably the 95 thread then this really
really problematic I'm losing him so I
should have gone to e form yeah me this
is very logical yeah you have to take
almost with white and then like here I'm
just going d5 96 just developed quickly
and the king is very unsafe yeah and in
them in the actual game Iraq
to move the Rukia and they don't have
something here yeah this now initially I
was thinking rookie - and of course just
Queen tags and there is the maid thread
this is the problem what a wacky game
yeah but it was it was entertaining yeah
thanks a lot for watching